[Music]  you know a lot of people have heard my  story I've been very open about it but a  lot of people don't know what my life is  like today and I'm turning 25 you get to  get to go on that journey with me you  have planned yes I am going to the Conor  McGregor Floyd Mayweather fight that's  me that's all I've been looking forward  to doing it's like ever since the fight  was announced I was like I'm going to  that fight it's gonna be amazing and I  can't wait to see the win are you going  with friends or I'll go with friends and  yeah that's what I think about when I  think about my 25th birthday I don't  even have a party planned I'm just  thinking about the fight  [Music]  you